look at this there's more than 3.2
million people in New York City that
were born outside of the United States
that makes New York City by a wide
margin the city with the most
foreign-born people of any other city in
the world
[Music]
I'm sure Thorpe I'm a National
Geographic hello and I would aid artists
what that means is if I try to take data
and put it into a context they might not
expect so that could be turning it into
a series of shapes or series of colors
or a series of different types of
designs the deceased is called we were
strangers once too it what it is is it
33 metal poles that are inscribed with
the immigration statistics for New York
City so what it represents is three
points two million people in New York
City that are foreign born they were
born outside of the United States every
thousand of those people is represented
by an inch of paint on these pole
as you approach the front of the
sculpture we've positioned all the color
blocks perfectly so that they form a
heart and so we wanted to put that right
in the center of this video as a
statement to say to say that the beating
heart of the city are immigrants and and
also to show the incredible diversity of
the immigrant population in New York
City more than any other city in the
world this one is built by immigrants
that original name for the city was Co
Amsterdam it was a new in the name it
still has new in the name so Vista T is
nothing without immigrants it's what we
are as New Yorker
[Music]